good morning Hank it's Wednesday July
26th VidCon starts tomorrow and I have
lots of exciting announcements today
beginning with the boxes behind what
what are you doing there
signing books we'll get out of the frame
all right Oh
clones Hank you can't live with them and
you can't sign a crap ton of books
without them sohave exciting
announcement number one penguin has
moved the publication date of the Fault
in Our Stars forward by five months from
May 1st to January 10th the book will
now be published on January 10th 2012
they called me and they were like we've
been watching the comments on your
internet television show and it appears
that the nerdfighters would like the
book to come out before May and I was
like yeah of course they would so would
I and then poof it happened nerdfighters
I cannot thank you enough if it weren't
for your hardcore pre-ordering people
would have to wait until May to read
this book but because you are awesome
they get to read it five months earlier
but hey then there's the small matter of
having agreed to autograph every copy of
the first printing of The Fault in Our
Stars I knew that would be quite an
endeavor but um yeah the Yeti actually
made me a thermometer to help me chart
my progress all the way to a hundred and
fifty thousand books showing we've
learned never to underestimate
nerdfighters right I mean these are
people who raised 150 thousand dollars
in 48 hours during a project for awesome
people who got your album on the
Billboard charts people who chartered
airplanes full of life-saving medical
supplies to Haiti people who got Helen
Hunt to hear the Helen Hunt song and
threatened you with a restraining order
and yet it seems I have managed again to
underestimate nerdfighteria Hank
nerdfighter recently guessed on her blog
that I'd have to sign 70,000 books in
about 180 days and according to her
calculations I couldn't do it well I
have to sign twice that many books in
half that much time and I'm gonna do it
I'm just not quite sure how so I'm gonna
call brother 2.0 resident mathematician
and Illinois State Representative Daniel
Biss so I have to sign a hundred and
fifty thousand copies of The Fault in
Our Stars two thousand books a day yeah
I mean it's not a lot of books to do in
one day it's a lot of books to do 75
days in a row so these boxes contain
150,000 pages I sign each of them and
then they go to Pennsylvania
we're together with the rest of the
pages in The Fault in Our Stars they are
found and there's a cover which I would
like to show you but it doesn't exist
yet
although here are some awesome covers
designed by nerdfighters so I've got a
couple things working in my favor here
number one my signature like my rap name
is J scribble relatively straightforward
in fact this is the first one I signed I
should probably write a little note or
something this was the first one cool
note bro and number two I really want to
sign all these books for you because I
like the idea of all these signed books
going into awesome nerd fight astok
Holmes it's like if I had a ton of
puppies and they all got adopted by
awesome people
long story short all pre-orders no
matter where you live the US the UK
Canada Malaysia all three orders of The
Fault in Our Stars will be signed I
promise I'm gonna get it done
links in the doobly-doo which is now
sometimes kind of over here if you're
watching on the aggresive Panda
and lastly egg there is the question of
sharpie color nerdfighters voted and
they pull in your pants about which
color sharpie I should use to sign these
books green one but I don't really
ascribe to winner-take-all philosophy so
I'm gonna do it like a German Federal
Parliament where it's like 40% green 20%
purple etc oh there's one more awesome
announcement next year's VidCon will be
at the Anaheim Convention Center even if
you can't go to this year's VidCon you
can go to VidCon comm and sign up to
find more about next year Hank I will
see you tomorrow